there's been a lot of turmoil a lot of
ups and downs back and forth you
traditionally been pretty bullish on
shock always shot China has it any
tempered your enthusiasm the extent of
the Chinese government intervention and
the markets both equity markets in and
FX market not over time I mean it it's I
mean this country has gone through in a
couple of world wars in the 20th century
the Great Depression went through a
civil war I mean we we've had lots of
ups and downs in this country but
overall we've kept moving forward and
China will be the same so long time term
you're bigger China has got it's got a
long way don't see opportunities right
that you've done some investing there a
little bit of investing there and and
and we're open to ideas any place any
we've got a number of factories there
but you know capital travels expanded
beyond China to what extent of any are
you concerned that there may be
indications of more global slowdown I
mean you've got China slowing down we're
not sure really quite how much because
we're not sure about the numbers
Brazil's in and out it looks like it's
going to be there for a while us numbers
are fair to middling I mean they sort of
range around Europe is growing some but
pretty slowly do you think we should be
concerned at all about a global turned
out if so what from a policy point of
view could be done well I think it's
unlikely that the world are some great
slowdown but it always can I mean you
look at history and it's not been a
straight line in this country or any
other place but what I look at is five
or 10 or 20 years out and there's no way
that America is not going to make
progress China is not gonna make
progress Europe you're not going to make
progress over that period of time I
can't predict the you know the ups and
downs in between but but I don't know
how to do it but I do know that the tide
is it's really with humans I mean we we
learn more and more all the time about
how to unleash
human potential with the same people
we're 200 years ago but look at how
we're living compared to that it was all
inside but rule of law market system
equality of opportunity none of which
are perfect but as we push out on those
the world moves forward